[Music]
time to crush the system
you are the first trans man to ever
compete on that show like that is
historic um looking back now does that
still really carry like a huge weight
with you knowing that you are that
person that so many people out there
feel represented by on television oh my
god beyond yes i always wanted to see
myself in someone in the media and it
like
prevented me from transitioning for so
long because i was just
not really seeing it and any trans
medicine representation i saw was just
not something i connected with and so
just the fact that i was able to have
this platform in a
community that i love so much and
to showcase an art form that i've worked
my whole life to get good at and trained
for it was just i got to go on and be
myself and show my art and open so many
doors for people and then be the person
that i've always wanted to see so it's
just still so mind-blowing and amazing
to this day listen another stage you
were on that like
would be just completely like the cause
of my death is recently the savage by
fenty volume 3 show
[Music]
if i got a call saying uh rihanna would
love for you to walk in the savage show
i think i would like hang up my phone
and be like
this is a lie
i know it was so crazy it's her show and
she obviously is just so hands-on with
it and she picks who she wants and has
such a good grip on what representation
matters and she just makes sure like so
many different people from every
spectrum there ever is and life is like
are there and i've never been in a more
amazingly accepting community and show
in my entire life there are so many
celebrities who are fans of you ariana
grande you had a little back and forth
on twitter like how cute is that that
ariana grande is trying to do got mixed
makeup
help me oh my god that's not about that
guess who doesn't know how to do drag
makeup
i love you that was the funniest story
ever to me because she's just
the funniest person literally ever i
have we have like a few mutual stylists
and designers and they'll literally tell
me about how
she's on she's out of fitting or
something and it's like comedy central
she's just like cracking jokes like full
stand up routines and they just all are
dying laughing with her and like we just
dm sometimes and she literally just
makes me laugh because she's just so
she's just hilarious i'm obsessed with
her i'm obsessed with her too you are
going across north america on the night
of the living drag tour there are two
tour dates right here in canada toronto
and vancouver i will be there at the
toronto show i cannot wait this is one
of the most exciting towards me ever
first of all because i'm just a
halloween freak this tour is all about
us every
queen in the show is has to die in a
specific way and i feel like i have
heard what most of these girls are doing
and it's very everyone's pretty much
staying true to themselves and their art
forms of course violet tchotchke is
hosting the shows i love violet so much
like violet has this super sharp sense
of humor and i know you and violet are
pretty good friends like how does it
feel to be going across north america
with like a bff like does it even feel
like work some days it literally doesn't
and violet is
just
someone that my soul needed to enter my
life we've been friends for a very very
very long time and she's just taught me
so much about drag myself she's like the
older sister best friend that i've
always wanted in my life and we got to
tour a little bit on drive and drag a
few months ago together and it was just
so fun you have painted some faces of
incredible people in the entertainment
industry like heidi klum lil na's x
paris hilton who of course you did on
snatch games so incredibly you're so
obsessed with me it's everything i kind
of am i'm obsessed with you you're so
hot so i have to ask if you were to beat
the face of any celebrity like
dream big who would it be and why i
really want to paint rupaul
at some point
i really want to paint cher
and i want to paint
dolly parton
ionic basically staying in the drag
queen realm obviously just all gay icons